oh my gosh it's such an amazing morning
here at Drakon we have a silky nutmeg a
notch walking up to the booth yeah we
are live here for a cops away night
scene at the LA Convention Center oh she
is moving she is moving the setting the
shrubbery all right all right soaking up
a notch everyone how are you feeling
good morning how are you I'm good what's
good seeing you again you too bright the
party hello hello Wow
what was it like to walk down that and
feel all that energy you know what
online I'm the most hated no give a road
bike but the reality of it is in person
I am truly loved and I appreciate that
that little old me a little boy from
Mississippi could come to LA and be
loved in a septic that's the beautiful
thing about the LGBT community when we
choose to show it but me make sure you
show a lot of love over the these next
five months do you feel like a star
today oh I felt like a star when I've
got walked in the workroom for the first
time
there you go felt like a star in high
school when I was running but trying
halftime shows I think now I feel like a
star and I'm actually making a little
bit of money honey
well you just a little bit you look
amazing to the hamburger season 11 so
okay you're a star here who are you
excited to see from the shows from your
favorite track celebrities oh my
goodness I you know the dream girls make
sure you come see us the kiria who is
having a quad the end miss Vangie who
has a laundromat also excited to see
seven against judges that was so
wonderful so fabulous you know what
it's hotter than a jalapeno scoochie in
here drag is not easy but you know what
it's not really the celebrities that I'm
excited to sing it's more so of
then-common fans are called young family
because the reality of it is for me I am
using the example by being on RuPaul's
Drag Race
I share similar stories to a lot of
people in America and I yest erday why
was that direct con and this lady came
up and she said I stopped doing Warren
in school 15 years ago and you inspired
me to go back to school
and those are the stories that I want to
hear that people are empowering
themselves I got on this show to empower
myself and to show my family a bigger
world and gratefully I took my
grandmother to London last show she's
never been out the country under four
and you know these are the things
they're beautiful stories that people
that need to hear no matter if you're
gay straight black white blue yellow
green polka dot these are the true
American stories that need to be told
but as your grandma is still rooting for
a period away yes she made sure I let
everybody know because my grandmother
loves Acurio and she did she see herself
in a carrier and I think that's
beautiful that a 82 year old lady can
find you know a common ground with a 30
year old drag queen silky nut mega now
here at the et live stage at Drakon 2019
I want to flirt hanging out with you and
you drive away thank you mwah
by having me over sorry I'm a little I'm
not sweaty I'm glistening I'm a Southern
woman this is a glow cut of my boots and
by some [ __ ] let me tell you we
trackways are in debt especially season
11 girls
we just can't prepare for the finale
last week then they say drag climb this
week we are in debt and if you don't
come get us American and French ethnic
are these
a Bank of America Chase Bank will come
get us with their collection services so
make sure you can't get us baby alright